speaking of Jordan Peterson Jordan
Peterson was on a very small podcast on
the computer machine you may have heard
of this thing it's called The Joe Rogan
Experience and he was on a couple days
ago and they started talking about
what's going on with the world economic
Forum what is going on with these people
who meet to decide that top-down layer
of we control you down there I thought
this was quite good
I've been trying to understand the
driving ideas underneath this globalist
utopian tyranny that seems to be
developing from the top down and I think
it's driven at least in part by this
religious Vision that I already
described you know that you have to
construe culture itself especially
industrial culture as the tyrannical
father raping and pillaging everything
in its way which is unbelievably
dangerous way to think to one-sided and
uh the the the idea that you have to
impose limits to growth on people in
order to have a sustainable planet and
so when I look at ideas like that that
first assumption you know the planet has
too many people on it it's like I don't
like to hear people say that because
when I hear that I think okay buddy who
exactly are you thinking about getting
rid of oh well it's not like that it's
like yeah it's like that it has to be
like it is absolutely like that like
I've already felt that I'd be that war
for the last six months and I would say
it's War because what I observed
happening in Europe when I was there
last was that well you can see this you
don't have to be in Europe to see it but
it's more direct if you're there is that
it's pretty damn clear that the
globalist utopians are willing to
sacrifice the poor for the sake of the
planet it's like that'd be fine with me
not really that'd be fine with me if the
consequence of your actions raising
Energy prices for example actually prove
produced an improvement in those things
you wanted to improve if you're if
you're a cure for the planet is well you
know we got to put 350 million poor
people in Jeopardy just so that things
are hypothetically better in 100 years I
think yeah I don't think so buddy and
also it's a little bit too convenient
for me that your prescriptions to save
the planet are accompanied by this
insistence that the only way forward to
that is to give you all the power it's
like there's a bit of a moral hazard in
that don't you think it's like I'm just
saving the planet give me all the power
it's like you want to save the planet or
do you want the power and let's let's
put the first the second one first
because the probability that you're a
saint or the Messiah is pretty damn low
oh man he's good he just gets it he's
good
um look this top down thing it ain't
working and we must fight it and I love
that Jordan said I feel like I've been
at War for the last six months you know
I I happen to know Jordan pretty well I
think he's been at War for a lot longer
I think we're all at War at some level I
think this Divergence that I'm talking
about uh it's going to lead us to a very
weird place so we need more people to
come down the path that I'm trying to
lay out for you guys right here and I
think it actually is happening
[Music]
foreign